hello everyone welcome to the highlight
show of class chess international
my name is sativa brahamian and i'm
going to take you to the key moment of
day 2.
if you watch my other highlight show
then you must be familiar with the
format of the tournament so yesterday we
had two exciting matches between
magnus carlson and jeffrey zhang and mvl
and wesley saw
so today those players were taking the
rest and we had two other matches with
fabiano carolina versus uh lanier
dominguez and we also had
alexander christian versus levon aronian
so at the end of the day both
fabiano and levin arunian are leading
over their opponents and i will
take you to the games and talk about
exactly what happened in the day
so let's get started with the match
between fabiano caruana and lanier
dominguez
if you watched the first edition of
clutch just and
you saw that they actually played
against each other in the first edition
and
fabiano carona completely destroyed his
opponent and
dominguez actually scored only one
victory in the entire match
which must have been demoralizing and
the main culprit of the result was his
poor time management
so in the game one dominguez got his
revenge and he just got a crushing
position out of the opening
so let's start on move ten we had this
karo khan defense
and uh dominguez goes d5 just crashing
through the position
uh threatening to put a pawn on f6
asking this bishop where it's going
and forcing his opponent to take and now
after e6
sacrificing another pawn temporarily
stopping his opponent from castling
97 and now developing the pieces
knight goes to g5 and the position is
extremely unpleasant for
black and it actually was surprising
that it lasted as long as it did
so after takes on g5
um dominguez decides to simply win the
pawn back
brings his uh pieces into the game and
the material is equal except we notice
that there is a king on g6 so yasser was
joking you know and say
bring all the pieces to the game but it
doesn't involve the king
but here we are so knight g5
um doubling the rooks
rook on the seven rank queen comes back
pinning the rook
so there's actually another moment in
the game that i want you i want to take
you to
winning the pawn so now we're going to
see all the damage that this knight does
to the position threatening the pawn on
g7
threatening to play rook b8 check really
hard to
deal with all these threads so the king
runs
so knight g5 carried this threat of
queen e8
um so rook b8 was played but see if you
can find a better move maybe you can
pause the video
so this is um kind of like a puzzle rush
kind of tactic
you can simply take
and just collect everyone and eventually
checkmate
instead rook b8 was played but the
position is so winning at this point it
doesn't really matter
so now it takes
the rook penetrates once again
takes again and now it's game over
because
black is going to lose a lot of material
so that was getting game one and
dominguez started
on a very good note by winning um
such a dominating fashion with the white
pieces and
defeating an opponent he had such a hard
time with in the first edition of the
same tournament
so let's go to the next game and let's
jump
to move 37. so fabiano now has the white
pieces
and material is equal but he does have a
bishop for a knight and he tries very
hard to press for a win
f5 rook on the seventh rank giving up
the pawn just to get this dominating
bishop
so winning the pawn back
because of this pin and this mating net
there's impossible to move this rook of
course
bishop c7 but now dominguez decides to
go for this end game of rogue bishop
versus rook which theoretically is
a draw with best play but practically
it's not so easy to do and it's very
easy to mess up both the defense and the
offense like you can find yourself in a
winning position but if you don't know
how to win
can very easily just mess it up
uh so i will just take you to the ending
of the game says here simply white just
starts taking this pawns
so there isn't as much commentary to do
here so of course we don't want to trade
rooks
so he's going to zukswanki's opponent
so eventually we see this pawn is going
to fall
so pawn fell and king e6 which is very
unfortunate
the commentaries thought well actually
yesterday thought that it was a mild
sleep and king d6
was the move that fabiano meant to play
but now
unfortunately after rookie two which was
played in the game
uh the bishop falls so king d7
and the king versus king and the game in
the in the dinner drum
and so now the result is one i have to
have in favor of
linear so let's go back to our next game
where fabiano has
the black pieces one more time and this
was really the turning point in the
tournament
because something really
tragic happened in this game in terms of
chess
so on move 41 so we have this position
where the material is equal and
everything looks normal and
looks like game is peering out to a drop
but
dominguez makes this uh careless
mistakes mistake of just taking this
pawn on e5
and this looks quite harmless it looks
like everything is just going to be
traded and the game is going to end in a
draw
but unfortunately after rookie 5 king f2
rook e2 bishop g4
we traded down to last king and pawn end
game so here he resigned
because after take take
and this is a very simple draw because
black is just up upon he will create a
pass pawn and the king will run to the
other side and collect everyone
so this was a very devastating loss for
dominguez who
had a leading score and now the match is
tied one i have a one and a half
so now let's take a look at game four so
if we look at the position
uh looks quite pleasant for white um
white
has a rook on the seven rank has
rooks um controlling the only open file
the queen is active
it looks uh pleasant maybe nothing uh
directly but
um if you had to choose a side you
probably would choose to be white in
this position
so rook b1 was played
and here a big mistake was made knight
a5
so if you look at the position it is the
main weakness in white's position this
pawn doesn't look like it's going to
survive
but after 95 knight a5 now
the knight can go to e5 because that was
knight that's what knight
on c4 was doing it was controlling the
e5 square
so 995 and now black is left with this
really atrocious pawn structure
and the spawn is also weak and now we're
going to see fabiano's
excellent technique so knight g4
attacking the pawns
b6 because if the knight moves
and this pawns are just going to fall
one by one because if you take a look at
this knight this is actually a very
poorly placed piece
so for example if you try rook p8
we can try um you can try rook a6 but
even let's say we go 93 asking how how
is black going to defend the spawn so
this movie is impossible
and if rook d8 and rook a6 and asking
where this knight is going so it becomes
very difficult for black to defend
everything because there's just too many
weaknesses in the position
so instead of instead v6 was played
and now fabiano starts to collecting
pawns
defends everything
winning a pawn
winning another pawn and rookie seven
very nice tactical resource as both his
pieces were under attack but he saves
both of them
and after kanye too dominguez just
resigns because
he's just down too much material and
it's hard to believe that black is going
to hang on to all his pawns because
there are just so many weaknesses and
once the king penetrates once one of the
spawn stars moving
position is just going to fall apart so
dominguez started with a one point lead
but now he fell
a full point behind after losing two
games in a row so next
up next are the two clutch games where
each moon is worth two points and a draw
is one point
so let's jump right into our first
clutch game where
linear dominguez has the white pieces uh
so this was actually a karo khan so as
we see fabiano
um fabian's position didn't fall apart
of the opening as it did in the first
game
so position looks quite um nice for
black even though he's down the pawn
because his pieces are very active this
rook is very misplaced
and it it's hard to believe that this
pawn is just going to survive
so he plays king g2 which is uh
kind of a strange move putting the king
on the lights square when there's this
weak diagonal
so queen a5 giving up the pawn
knight c2 and we see that
black is going to win an exchange either
by checking on e3 or by forcing white to
take here which he did and the game ends
very quickly
takes and queen c1
and here resigns because queen k4 is
made
and this move actually runs into the
very beautiful
queen a1
and checkmate once again so really nice
win by fabiano caruana who now takes a
three-point lead over his opponent even
though he started with
a pointless so let's take a look at our
final game of this match
where fabiano corona has the white
pieces
uh so we have this position where white
is down upon
but he's again he has a bishop versus a
knight and he's trying very hard to
press for a win
and he does have a big uh time advantage
so bishop goes to z6
um eyeing this g7 pawn and here
dominguez finds a very nice resource
because king f5 bishop f8
as rook g7 would run into 94
but 94 anyways
because if not 94 let's say you make
some kind of a move
then now rook g7 can be very dangerous
threatening meat
but now with the knight on e4 black is
defending
by threatening his own checkmate so
white has no choice but to make a drum
and tomorrow they are going to rest and
their match will resume on tuesday
so the other match that we have was
between lavon aronian and alexander
krischuk so levon aronian also took a
big lead over his
his opponent so this was a very up and
down match
a lot of back and forth a lot of
entertaining games a lot of
really instructive games so we're going
to take a look
at every single one of them so let's get
started with the first one level
naronian has the white pieces
so lemon was doing really well in this
game with the white pieces but at some
point he starts to
push too hard and things go wrong
so he plays rook c7 giving up the pawn
and to push this pawn attack the pawn on
f7
and after king e5 bishop d5
and now he blunders with this move and
the problem is
after take rook c8 black just gives
up the rook and now black is just up way
too many pawns
so he has a bishop and three pawns for
rook and we're going to see how this is
just way too much material for
white to cope with
and i will destroy the rest of the game
um again this was just a matter of
technique and gracious handled it quite
well
so now it's just pushing the pawns and
it's really hard to suggest big
improvements for white because
objectively wise
position should just be lost
and it's going to become very difficult
to cope with all these past pawns
because
even if rook can stop two pawns
black will create another pass pawn on
the other side of the board
and so he chose to put
to run with the king to the queen side
but had he
left a rook on the queen side then
grisha
simply would have created a pass pawn on
the king's side distracting the king and
running his own king to the queen side
so here he's just uh so here he did the
opposite
so he has a past pawn here where his
opponent has to be distracted by
and two of them on this side
and it's just impossible to stop all of
these guys because ru cannot go to g8
this one starts to run we will shoulder
the king
the king will go to f3 and the spawn
will just run because the king won't be
able to get in on time
so a really nice game by
alexander krischuk bouncing back from a
tough position and
taking his opportunity as it presents
itself so now now let's go back
and let's go to our second game now
christchurch has the
white pieces and this game could have
really ended in a disaster for levan
arunian but
he found some good resources when he
needed them and
survived so in this position
we see the weakness of this kink but
there is a knight here so kind of looks
safe as there are no minor pieces to
penetrate because this knight is blocked
there are no bishops and this d5 pawn
looks quite weak
so rook d4 was played
trying to trade coins and now rook h7 a
really nice blow in the position
uh and very unpleasant to face a move
like this when
you know you're offering a queen trade
and looks like this queen may not have
an escape square
because the after pawn is also hanging
so it feels like
white is forced to trade queens here now
queen f6
and now we see the unpleasantness f7
hanging so you cannot take
this guy is hanging and besides having a
really
weak king black is going to be down some
material
science that rook fade was played and
here
krishuk made a critical error which uh
feels like a very natural move and the
alternative is kind of hard to
find i think because that's less of a
natural move and not where your mind
goes
so he played 95 which was a mistake and
knight h4 would have been the winning
move
so the threat is simple to go knight f5
so to demonstrate if i just pass the
move for black
threatening mate so let's say rook g8
and now we can do
a very pretty checkmate
so after knight h4 um kind of hard to
suggest good moves for black
because taking is impossible
and maybe roxy4 is a try
but after knight g6 if you try to take
back i will check
and take and once again this king it's
hard to believe this king is going to
survive forever a long time
but luckily for 11 95 was played so king
goes back
this is defended rook g4 and queen c3
really great resource
pinning the queen stopping any kind of
knight g6 moves
so f4 defending the knight takes the
pawn
so gracious decides to sacrifice so of
course he can take a drop but he decides
to play on after a couple of repetitions
so he takes the rook and goes forward
down an exchange position but
um with limited material and the skin
also
a little bit vulnerable uh black makes
the draw quite comfortably here
i know it doesn't look comfortable
because it looks so scary but
we are talking about the top players in
the world so rookie went back
so there's a lot of repetitions so i
don't need to focus on every single one
of this
so eventually we go to this position but
now we have two versus two
and if white starts pushing this pawn
then in turn he's going to weaken his
king
inviting perpetuals and
white is pushing their pawns black is
pushing there so the game period
to draw very quickly
with a perpetual
so a nice escape by levon aronian
which could have been a 2-0 start which
is tough to start with two losses in a
row
so let's jump to our third game where
eleven our onion has the white pieces
the win equalize the match and
put levon back on the scoreboard so
let's jump
rookie 5 f6 and he decides to make very
practical decision of sacrificing
the exchange
trading and we see just in the long term
and with little time on his click is
going to be very difficult to cope with
the structure
and white is going to be winning a lot
of material
so knight comes back and now bla white
is not even
playing for the attack is just simply
playing up material
improving the king pushing the pawn
putting a knight on an excellent square
the pawn on f5 was hanging
and a very beautiful checkmate
didn't play until checkmate but of
course this is very
aesthetically pleasing to deliver
something like this on the board
unfortunately didn't happen he resigned
but this would have been great
the next game ended in a drum karishchuk
was again in the driver's seat he had
some pretty good chances of winning but
things didn't really go his way
and this was the key position
on excuse me on move 33
so he's up a pawn he's pressing and
he is he should have played h3 at some
point giving his king some room
trying like queen f2 excuse me queen g4
trying to harass this queen exchange it
because the bishop is controlling this
very important e2 square
place here the king comes back
and now the queen gets to this good
square of f5
so we got to this end game but
unfortunately there isn't much to play
for
and the main reason is
a wrong color bishop so we see
that one makes draw makes the draw quite
easily
by giving up this knight and we know
that because this is a light square
bishop
and this is the wrong corner the game
ends in a drum
so the next two games are pretty crazy
games where it
mulches and some critical moments
if you want to work on your rook and
games i would really advise you take a
deep look into these games and
really analyze them and maybe practice
with someone to really understand how
to win rogan games because we know
notoriously it's very difficult to win
them even if you're up material
and one of the reasons is now rooks are
powerful pieces so they have get a lot
of resources and another is
by the time you reach the uh the end
game you don't have a lot of time on
your clock so it's very easy to make
mistakes
as we see here so in this position so
level one is up a pawn
so he checks and goes back so instead he
should have just put his rook on the
fourth rank
excuse me on the fourth rank defending
everyone
cutting this king off and just bring
wrong wrong arrows just bring his king
around to assist this pawn and
eventually push this pawn
instead he decides that you know the
rule that we all know that
rooks belong behind past bonds so that's
what he does
but in turn his own king gets cut off
and now rook goes to the other side now
that the rook is here
to stop this pawn black gets a lot of
activity
and now it's impossible for white to
make progress without giving up a pawn
so he tries
he pushes the pawn but now the pawn is
under attack
and what to do the king cannot get in
so he decides to give up the pawn and we
reach this position
so white has the b pawn they're trying
to queen and black has the h pawn
so white starts to push their pawn
blocks pushes theirs
stopping this pawn and starting pushing
their pawn
so check push
a couple more checks here
and this should be a drop because there
is no luceno defense because of this
pawn so white doesn't have the chance to
do that
and as the king runs
it will get checked and here actually
um grishook made a
big error but it wasn't taken advantage
of i think one of the reasons is because
levon didn't think there is anything to
take advantage of in this position
because he probably thought it's just a
draw
but he blunders with this move and the
reason this is a blunder because now the
king has
can run because the idea of the defense
is to check
check and as soon as my king leaves the
pawn
you put your rook behind the pawn except
here white has the opportunity of taking
on h2
and now you cannot take because
of this x-ray
and so black's uh best option is to take
the rook and play this
so we didn't see this in this in this
game but don't worry we will see this
end game in the next one
so we will see this position eventually
but this wasn't found in the game again
time trouble
so the king comes here to assist the
pawn so what
black is going to do he's going to give
up the rook for this pawn
and because this pawn is so far advanced
the king will assist it with queening
and it will end up king vs king
so king rook c7
king g3 take and we have king vs king
so the match was tight now but we have
one more final game
and this was a clutch game which ended
in a drone the next one is also the
final game the clutch game where a win
is worth two points
so again we have some kind of a rook end
game i want
um one side is pushing their pawn the
other side is pushing their pawn
so g7 k7
so instead uh here white should really
keep checking this king because the king
cannot really hide
now we're threatening to take distract
the rogue and queen so this is going to
be a very easy draw
uh instead he decides to play g8 queen
takes takes and now c3 and now we're
going to see there are some tricks in
the position
does rook c8 and
and the problem is now if rook c3 king
b2 and the rook cannot go anywhere to
stop this pawn so this actually
just loses so the pawn is untouchable
so you can get someone is played
and now this king is just going to run
away
uh so king f checking after you and the
rook came back
i king of three was a mistake i should
mention that king d4 should have been
played
and i will show you viking after it was
a mistake
uh so after king f3 rookie one
c2 king comes here king f2 and now this
last change that
last chance that christian cat to make a
draw in this position so instead of
playing rook a1 he went to the other
side of the board
and this would have been a draw because
let's say here
and now
and now the king comes from the side
king three comes after the stroke and
king detune you're just in time
so now you can take the pawn or just be
fancy and make a draw like this
but instead gage1 was played and now
unfortunately he is
one move behind so we enter this end
game
and this end game goes on for a while so
i will
just play through it and i will show you
one more key moment where it could have
been one a little easier
so the king comes in so you have to know
how to win this end game it's not easy
to win at all because
there are some uh some drawing chances
some
stalemate uh positions that you can run
into
so queen e5
and yeah so in this position there's an
easier way to win
so instead of queen c7 check queen g5
check is actually simply winning because
the king just doesn't have
a good square to go to this runs into
this
kinky six runs into the same thing
it's looking good right this is the same
thing this runs into the d8
and uh we're running out of moves right
so this is the only option
and this is a zucchini because actually
this is just made right
because if you go here you get made it
on b8 if you go here you also get made
it on b8
so very unfortunate but instead queen c7
was played so there are some more
adventures in this game
so actually we're going to see the king
runs all the way to the other side of
the board
so harassing the rook and eventually
this rook
does not survive
and we ended with a checkmate on the
board so christian was very cheated
after the game it was actually really
late for him it was 1 30 for him
around two o'clock and around three
o'clock for levon
so he didn't really want to talk a lot
in this post-game interview
and that one himself said that his games
were below their level
he did joke that it's too late and he's
not used to playing chess
this late but it wasn't really the
excuse like he didn't use that as an
excuse it's just something he pointed
out pointed out
but he did he didn't seem too happy with
the quality of the games but he was
quite happy to have won this game
because
he did realize that rookie one was a
draw so as i mentioned um those
these four players are going to take a
break tomorrow
so we're going to see the other matches
that we signed day one so carlson versus
zhang and
nbl versus wesley song so thank you
everyone for watching this highlight
video
i hope you enjoyed it if you want to see
this
this games in detail then check out usgs
champs and you can look through them
play through them and analyze them
otherwise make sure you're checking out
the broadcast tomorrow starting at 1pm
central